merci Philippe Bas de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de la Manche donc du groupe les
républicains questeurs du Sénat et on va
évidemment parler du texte dont vous
êtes le rapporteur texte sur la
reconnaissance biométrique on va voir ça
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité on l'a vu c'est cette notion
de son sur qui a donc été rejeté hier à
50 voix il a manqué 50 voix pour faire
tomber le gouvernement c'est la 17e
motion de censure est-ce que hier le
gouvernement peut dire merci aux
républicain
voter une motion de censure
c'est être prêt à opposer un
gouvernement et à une politique et un
programme d'action un autre gouvernement
une autre politique un autre programme
d'action
vous ne pouvez pas faire une politique
avec le rassemblement national avec la
nupesse
et par conséquent vous ne pouvez pas
voter avec eux une motion de censure
sinon vous êtes irresponsable il n'y a
pas de coalition possible pour nous avec
les extrémistes nous les combattons
et par conséquent il était hors de
question je pense de s'associer à cette
initiative et ce qui n'a pas empêché
lors de la précédente notion de censure
une vingtaine de députés républicains de
la beauté mais avec la nuit avec le
rassemblement déjà et pour les mêmes
raisons cet acte on peut bien sûr être
posé à la réforme des retraites on peut
dire que le dialogue social n'a pas eu
lieu souvenez-vous en 2003 la réforme
des retraites avait donné lieu à un
accord avec la CFDT et la CGC le
gouvernement avait fait des concessions
celui-ci n'en a pas fait et par
conséquent je comprends qu'aujourd'hui
il y est toujours de l'amertume face à
cette réforme même si une réforme était
nécessaire elle aurait pu être
évidemment différente
mais en tout état de cause le principe
démocratique c'est que vous ne votez pas
de motion de censure si vous n'êtes pas
prêt à gouverner avec les autres groupes
politiques qui ont déposé la motion de
censure regardez la dupeesse est-ce que
on peut décemment quand on est à
démocrate républicain responsable
s'associer à une formation politique qui
a fait de la démence de l'invective de
l'obstruction des attaques personnelles
son fonds de commerce politique et je
réponds non évidemment non à
l'extrémisme retournons à une pratique
démocratique des institutions
véritablement respectueuse des idées de
chacun et responsables
on entend les oppositions de dire que
Yaël brun Pivet ces derniers jours en
activant l'article 40 à abîmer le
Parlement est-ce que vous partagez cet
avis véritablement de personnalisons pas
le débat ainsi je crois que il y a des
règles dans notre Constitution il
appartient à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale de les faire
respecter quand le président de la
commission des Finances n'a pas fait son
devoir il a fait la politique
la marge de manœuvre pour interpréter
l'article 40 de la Constitution est très
faible et n'est-elle pas faire ce
qu'elle a fait ce Conseil
constitutionnel aurait été obligé de le
faire
on va parler de l'immigration puisque ce
qui s'est passé à Annecy jeudi dernier
et cette attaque au couteau à reposer la
question de la politique migratoire et
du droit d'asile est-ce que pour vous il
faut réformer le droit d'asile
nous devons et c'est l'honneur de la
France accueillir des personnes
persécutées dans leur pays en raison de
leur religion de leur origine de leur
action politique c'est une obligation
morale mais nous constatons depuis
longtemps et dans la période récente de
plus en plus qu'un certain nombre de
migrants en réalité
en situation irrégulière essaye de se
prévaloir d'un droit qu'ils n'ont pas et
qui ne leur sera d'ailleurs pas reconnu
quand on aura terminé la procédure
devant la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile ce sont plus de 60% des
candidats à l'asile qui sont déboutés et
tous ces déboutés savent très bien
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit à l'asile et
le demande quand même parce que pendant
toute la période d'étude de leur dossier
ils sont en situation temporairement
tolérées sur notre territoire le droit
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui nous avons
tout de même des réseaux de trafiquants
d'être humain qui se comporte d'une
manière extrêmement violente nous avons
des migrants qui arrivent en France non
seulement ils ont bravé tous les dangers
de la mer mais enfin nous avons des
jeunes femmes qui ont été violées qui
portent avec elles les enfants du viol
et qui arrivent sur notre territoire
national après avoir épuisé leur maigre
économies pour payer les passeurs c’est
un digne et ne serait-ce que pour des
raisons humanitaires il faut réformer ce
droit d'asile pour qu'il ne fasse pas
autant de victimes qu'aujourd'hui est-ce
que un compromis vous semble possible
avec le gouvernement sur un texte
immigration il y a notamment une ligne
rouge de votre part c'est cette question
de la régularisation des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension mais il y a
une ligne rouge sur votre texte de la
part du gouvernement c'est la question
de faire primer le droit national sur le
droit européen Gérald Darmanin dit c'est
un frexit migratoire et
devoir Philippe dit c'est un frexit
juridique qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas
raison je crois profondément que si nous
devons mettre en œuvre
un choc une rupture avec une politique
d'immigration qui a été trop laxiste et
qui a entraîné de grandes difficultés du
point de vue de notre cohésion nationale
et sociale il va falloir prendre des
mesures réellement énergiques et oui si
il y a sur tel ou tel des dispositions à
prendre des difficultés du point de vue
du droit européen il faudra d'abord en
discuter avec nous partenaires pour
faire évoluer le droit européen car la
France a un rôle déterminant dans les
règles qui sont appliquées en Europe et
elle a un rôle déterminant dans les
traités européens et si nous n'y
parvenons pas alors oui il faut se poser
la question de savoir si ponctuellement
nous ne devons pas modifier notre
Constitution pour faire en sorte que des
dispositions raisonnables qui relèvent
de notre étroit État de droit
républicain puisse être mise en œuvre ce
ne sont pas toutes les dispositions de
la politique de l'immigration nos marges
de manoeuvre sont grandes la politique
de l'immigration ne relève que
partiellement des questions européennes
de la libre circulation des frontières
européennes elles relèvent aussi du
droit d'entrée de ces jours en France
nous avons nos propres exigences et nous
devons les affirmer nous regardons
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe dans un
certain nombre de pays qui explore
jusqu'au marge leurs droits souverains
en matière de contrôle des frontières et
nous devons nous ne pas être en dessous
du niveau d'exigence qu'attendent les
Français pour assurer leur cohésion
nationale nous devons partager avec les
gens qui viennent en France les mêmes
exigences du point de vue de la vie
quotidienne du mode de vie nous devons
pour l'accès à la nationalité faire en
sorte que l'assimilation soit réelle et
ce faisant nous montrerons que la
République française et décidé à
défendre ses frontières d'autre part
mais aussi à accueillir ce qui respecte
notre droit et respecte nos modes de vie
ce qui s'est passé au Sénat hier puisque
le Sénat a voté un texte sur la
reconnaissance biométrique vous en êtes
le rapporteur on va voir les
explications et les temps forts de cette
séance avec Alex Moussa
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Philippe Bas
bonjour
la majorité de droite sénatoriale
propose d'encadrer et d'expérimenter la
reconnaissance faciale dans notre pays
ce texte prévoit d'expérimenter d'une
manière générale la reconnaissance
biométrique c'est à dire toutes les
techniques informatiques qui permet qui
permettent de reconnaître
automatiquement en individu à partir de
ces caractéristiques physiques
biologiques voire même comportementale
alors cela comprend plein de techniques
la reconnaissance par empreinte digitale
par le son de la voix par le scan de
l'iris mais on pense surtout à la
reconnaissance faciale alors ce texte de
la majorité sénatoriale d'abord il
définit un cadre juridique clair à
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
biométrique avec plusieurs interdictions
qui sont fixées d'abord interdiction de
catégoriser des personnes en fonction de
leur donner biométrique et puis
interdiction de les reconnaître en temps
réel dans l'espace public mais ce cadre
juridique voulu par les sénateurs et
bien il permet des dérogations et des
expérimentations de certaines techniques
de reconnaissance biométrique dans des
cas très précis par exemple on pourrait
utiliser cette reconnaissance
biométrique pour accéder à certains
grands événements à risque pour des
enquêtes judiciaires pour des
infractions d'une extrême gravité et
puis ce texte propose même
d'expérimenter la reconnaissance faciale
en temps réel dans des cas vraiment
extrêmes notamment lors d'attaque
terroristes alors ces expérimentations
elles se feraient sur une durée de trois
ans et elle serait contrôlée strictement
par le Parlement des expérimentations
qui sont jugées nécessaires par mcphe
Philippe daubrais le sénateur les
républicains du Nord auteur de ce texte
et puis auteur aussi un rapport sur le
sujet on l'écoute
pendant près de 30 ans
mon souvenir le plus douloureux c'est
celui de l'annonce que j'ai dû faire à
une famille de mes administrés que leur
fils de 27 ans avait été assassiné au
Bataclan par la barbarie islamiste et
terroriste et je m'étais juré à l'époque
comme parlementaire que nous ferions
tout pour garantir que plus jamais ça en
matière de tourisme bien sûr le risque
zéro n'existe pas mais il faut donner à
nos forces de l'ordre le maximum
d'outils pour y arriver voilà alors dans
le débat la gauche sénatoriale a dénoncé
un texte qui prépare selon elle une
société de surveillance on va écouter le
sénateur écologiste Thomas d'aussi à
chaque fois on commence par
expérimentations des dispositifs réduits
des initiatives que l'on nous jure
strictement encadrés et qui aboutissent
un variablement à leur généralisation
nos libertés publiques deviennent
secondaires pour les apprentis sociaux
de la société de surveillance nous
sortons à peine d'une loi là aussi
d'exception pour légaliser la
surveillance algorithmique durant les
Jeux Olympiques que les fanatiques du
flicage nous proposent déjà d'aller plus
loin le risque entités sert comme à
chaque fois de faune à la surveillance
globale
oui alors donc au final et bien la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
adopté ce texte sur la reconnaissance
biométrique mais peu de chances qu'il
soit utilisé pour les Jeux Olympiques
puisque le gouvernement est opposé à la
reconnaissance faciale et d'ailleurs
Gérald de Darmanin c'était exprimé sur
le sujet devant les sénateurs Philippe
Bas quand on met le doigt dans
l'engrenage de ces nouvelles
technologies notamment de la
reconnaissance faciale et ce qui n'a pas
le risque qu'on tombe dans une société
de la surveillance
alors d'abord ça n'était pas un débat à
droite-gauche hier parce que la
proposition de loi est issue d'un
rapport adopté à l'unanimité par la
commission des lois et dont l'un des
co-auteurs et membre du groupe
socialiste Jérôme Durand qui finalement
était opposé à ce texte oui parce que il
considérait qu'il fallait attendre le
texte européen et il ne s'est pas
prononcé contre le fond du texte c'est
lui qui est d'ailleurs été l'orateur du
groupe socialiste je crois qu'il faut
prendre garde à ne pas
prendre des positions qui soient des
positions en réalité extrême et
s'ennuyantes depuis la maîtrise du feu
jusqu'à la découverte de l'atome nous
connaissons bien l'ambivalence de tout
progrès scientifique mais si l'homme
préhistorique il y a maintenant près de
400000 euros avait dit le feu tu es
dangereux je n'y touche pas
et bien il n'aurait pas progressé dans
sa santé en cuisant les aliments et donc
oui tout progresse scientifique portant
lui le bien et le mal et l'homme ça
force c'est d'essayer d'en tirer tout le
bien possible sans verser dans les
menaces les dangers que ce progrès
technologique amène moi je vois bien
comme vous comme nous tous ce qu'on en
fait en Chine de la reconnaissance
faciale je vois bien que dans l'espace
public grâce à la reconnaissance faciale
on est en train de classer les individus
en fonction de leur comportement et on
leur donne des notes ce qui permet de
distribuer des avantages à certains
particulent les points comme si on
pouvait augmenter ses points de permis
pour prendre de l'avance en cas d'excès
de vitesse
et puis être pénalisé quand on se
comporte pas bien quand on ne traverse
pas dans les clous par exemple ceci
nous posons un interdit pour l'empêcher
en France ce qui se passe dans un régime
autoritaire nous n'en voulons pas dans
une république démocratique à l'évidence
mais est-ce que pour autant quand il
s'agit de lutter contre le terrorisme
quand il s'agit de retrouver un enfant
qui a été enlevé quand il s'agit de
combattre la grande criminalité et avec
des garanties l'autorité judiciaire
quand il s'agit de d'enquêtes judiciaire
la Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement et le
Conseil d'État quand il s'agit d'action
de renseignements ou de police le
contrôle des juridictions
de configurer les logiciels de
traitement avec une règle posée par
décret en Conseil d'État la
reconnaissance du rôle de la Commission
Nationale de l'Informatique et des
Libertés bref quand vous posez toutes
ces garanties et que vous restreignez
fortement les finalités de l'usage de la
reconnaissance faciale à des objectifs
absolument essentiels et même vitaux
alors vous faites ce travail de
recherche d'un bon équilibre qui permet
justement
d'incorporer à la vie de la société les
progrès technologiques et scientifiques
tout en mettant à l'écart les risques
qu'il comportent alors pour vous toutes
les garanties juridiques pour préserver
nos libertés sont posées ça a été mon
travail j'en ai rajouté même concernant
les Jeux Olympiques le gouvernement est
contre la reconnaissance faciale pour
sécuriser l'événement c'est une erreur
en ce qui concerne les Jeux Olympiques
il aurait dû effectivement considérer
que l'expérimentation car il s'agit
d'une expérimentation lui aurait permis
d'améliorer la sécurité nous avons mis
dans le texte qui a été adopté hier une
règle assez simple pour les personnels
ou les bénévoles les intervenants et
seulement pour certains lieux et
seulement avec des caméras dédiées et
seulement en cas de risque avéré
d'attentat terroristes une surveillance
par reconnaissance faciale biométrique
doit être rendu possible et que le
gouvernement accepte de l'expérimenter
pour faire rehausser encore les
garanties de sécurité qui le fasse pour
la Coupe du monde de rugby de toute
façon les règles que nous avons posées
hier si elles sont adoptées par
l'Assemblée nationale tombe
automatiquement au bout de trois ans et
il y aura un contrôle du Parlement
pendant leur mise en œuvre pour vérifier
que les choses se sont bien passées et
que elles ont permis effectivement
d'améliorer la sécurité sans mettre en
cause le respect de la vie privée et des
libertés merci Alex merci à tout à
l'heure on parlera du droit d'asile ça
sera le débat du club à suivre on va
voir l'actualité dans votre département
on va à Saint-Lô retrouver Edouard Frémy
bonjour Édouard merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteurs en chef adjoint à
la Manche Libre Édouard avec vous on va
parler de la pénurie de logement du
manque de foncier disponible qui sévit
dans votre région oui les choses
risquent risque de s'aggraver c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est difficile pour une
famille de trouver un appartement de
trouver une maison avec jardin dans le
département de la Manche les agents
immobiliers d'ailleurs font même plus la
pub ils ont des listes d'attentes et je
disais que les choses vont s'aggraver
parce que il y a depuis 2021 vous le
savez la loi climat et résilience qui
institut le zan le 0 artificialisation
nette des sols ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'en 2050 en 2050 dans moins de 30
ans pour un hectare construit un hectare
où on déroule du bitume ou du béton il
faudra rendre un plus tard à la nature
alors en ville il y a des friches
industrielles en ville il y a des
grandes surfaces commerciales en ville
on peut construire en hauteur mais à la
campagne à la campagne vous avez
l'église vous avez le bourg historique
autour vous avez peut-être une salle des
fêtes vous avez un lotissement parfois
une zone d'activité pour des TPE PME et
tout autour vous avez de la campagne
alors vous pouvez rien enlever de tout
cela si vous voulez construire vous
pourrez pas rendre de
l'artificialisation des sols pour
prendre sur la nature alors ça
s'apparente en tout cas c'est le risque
que pressente les élus locaux à une mise
sous cloche des territoires ruraux ou
finalement rien ne bouge les gens des
villes viennent passer le week-end
gentiment et puis il rentre le dimanche
soir chez eux et plus rien ne se
développe dans dans les territoires
ruraux la question qui se pose et que je
pose à Félix amateur de la Manche c'est
la France rural a-t-elle encore un
avenir ne risque-t-on pas de devenir
comme dit l'un de vos collègues une
réserve d'indiens finalement où plus
rien ne bouge
Philippe Édouard freiby pose une
question absolument fondamentale je
crois que dans notre territoire rural et
littoral c'est la question numéro 1
regardez nous posons des règles qui sont
pertinentes pour des espaces urbains et
périls urbains saturés et encombré
d'embouteillages tous les jours de
pollution avec une qualité de vie de
plus en plus médiocre et nous
déterminons ces règles pour ces
territoires métropolitains et nous les
appliquons au monde rural où il y a de
l'espace or il se trouve justement qu'un
département comme le nôtre
dont la population était de 500 000
habitants et maintenant tant vers 490
000 c'est une érosion lente mais
beaucoup d'urbains surtout depuis le
confinement le covid
veulent changer de mode de vie ils
viennent dans nos villages ils demandent
à nos élus est-ce qu'il y a des maisons
à vendre est-ce qu'il y a du terrain
constructible et les mères leur
répondent non je n'ai plus le droit à
cause du Zéro artificialisation nette
dont la justification est évidemment
n'est pas
pertinente dans le monde rural nous
avons une chance en France
avec notamment le télétravail de pouvoir
rééquilibrer notre aménagement du
territoire entre le monde rural et le
monde urbain ses vertueux pour le monde
urbain dont on dessererait les taux et
c'est nécessaire pour le développement
du monde rural et nous allons la des
règles imaginées par des polytechniciens
qui sont des règles mathématiques on
compte le foncier national et on le
répartit entre les départements puis
entre les bassonnes vie avec les plans
locaux d'urbanisme avec des règles
régionales qui se sur ajoutent et on se
retrouve dans la situation de ne pas
pouvoir permettre à des jeunes foyers
avec enfants de s'installer pour que les
enfants aillent dans nos écoles pour
maintenir celles-ci pour assurer le
développement de notre territoire qui
est pratiquement au plein emploi et qui
a besoin en plus de main d'oeuvre et
donc nous luttons j'ai déposé avec
Béatrice Gosselin et quelques collègues
un certain nombre de textes une
proposition de loi très importante sur
le rééquilibrage des territoires nous
avons voté ici au Sénat le mois dernier
une loi pour assouplir le zan nous avons
demandé au gouvernement de l'inscrire à
l'Assemblée nationale il a accepté de le
faire le 19 juin cette loi va peut-être
pas au bout du chemin et nous devrons
aller plus loin franchir de nouvelles
étapes mais nous souhaitons quelle autre
en vigueur car elle comporte ce que nous
avons appelé la garantie rurale aucune
commune rurale ne pourra se voir
interdire à l'intérieur du bourg de
construire moins de 1 hectare si elle
souhaite le faire s'il y a une demande
de nos familles pour pouvoir y
construire mais naturellement nous
devons aussi être vertueux c'est à dire
que quand il y a des logements vacants
nous devons tout faire pour les
réinjecter dans l'offre de logement mais
nous avons besoin de logement nous
devons le faire dans le respect de
l'agriculture nous devons le faire dans
le respect de nos zones naturelles mais
il y a encore de l'espace dans la Manche
et il y a un mode de vie extrêmement
attractif
peut-être une oui peut-être un sujet
connexe Philippe Bas qui est qui touche
le logement qui est plus saisonnier vous
me voyez venir je voudrais vous parler
d'Airbnb alors le département de la
Manche vous l'avez dit est un très beau
département qui attire beaucoup de
touristes ou un week-end soit en
vacances et c'est vrai que Airbnb est
consort constitue une concurrence au
logement des travailleurs locaux qui
n'ont évidemment pas le pouvoir d'achat
des gens qui viennent des grandes villes
et qui peuvent dépenser beaucoup pour un
week-end ou pour une semaine et le sujet
vraiment de cette concurrence du
logement par Airbnb vis-à-vis des
travers locaux commencent à se poser
faut-il entraver ou limiter ou mettre
des quotas pour Airbnb en particulier
sur les zones littérales pour préserver
le logement pour les travailleurs de la
Manche oui c'est simple vous voyez il y
a des logements disponibles c'est plus
avantageux pour leur propriétaire de est
loué pour les vacances que de les louer
à un jeune ménage de d'ouvriers ou de
salariés et de l'industrie agricole
enfin il faut donc essayer de faire en
sorte que c'est logement aillent aux
familles et non pas
systématiquement au touristes même si
nous devons nous parce que l'industrie
touristique dans la Manche est très très
importantes je vous recommande
d'ailleurs de venir nous voir pour le
constaterez et vous verrez notre
département est beau mais mais
point d'excès la priorité c'est le
logement des familles et par conséquent
j'ai voté c'est là une disposition qui
n'a pas été retenue parce que le
gouvernement s'y est opposé à
l'Assemblée nationale pour faire en
sorte que les locations
temporaires Airbnb soit davantage
contrôlé et taxé
merci Édouard merci beaucoup pour toutes
ces questions et ces sujets évidemment
très concernant on regarde la une de la
Manche Libre une exclusivité les
policiers de la Manche vous ont ouvert
leur stands de tir Edward au tire avec
les policiers c'est à la Une de votre
journal aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous Édouard Frémy un
mot de votre partie des républicains
célibat il y aura des états généraux de
la droite samedi qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de ces états généraux d'abord
je suis content que cette formation
politique qui connaît de grandes
difficultés ce soit remises au travail
parce que c'est le fond qui compte ça
n'est pas les apostrophes l'avaient
immense et la polémique et je crois que
si une force politique qui a une
tradition de force de gouvernement veut
retrouver sa crédibilité il faut que
elle aille au fond des choses les
Français
ils ne font pas confiance à une
formation politique qui fait la course à
la démagogie en revanche ils peuvent
faire conscience à une formation
politique fiable avec des idées des
idées à la fois fortes et raisonnable et
c'est cette crédibilité qu'il faut
construire j'observe ce qui est en train
de se passer avec ces conventions avec
espoir bien sûr et je crois qu'un
certain nombre de Français qui ne
veulent pas se laisser enfermer entre le
soutien au gouvernement et les
extrémismes ont envie que émergent une
force nouvelle et faire entendre et
comment les mettre en oeuvre les quatre
de renaissance vont se réunir à la
demande du chef de partie Stéphane
séjourné le 21 juin pour discuter d'une
alliance avec vous avec les républicains
qu'en pensez-vous mais il n'y a pas
d'alliance possible sans qu'il y ait un
programme commun d'envisager avec la
majorité présidentielle nous devons
d'abord déterminer nos propres positions
et les comparer à celle du gouvernement
mais si nous étions satisfaits de ce
gouvernement nous ne serions pas
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition or nous le
sommes pourra certaine nombre de raisons
où nous avons parlé tout à l'heure du
Zéro artificialisation nette ça n'est
pas notre politique d'aménagement du
territoire la situation des finances
publiques ça n'est pas notre politique
des finances publiques la situation de
l'immigration ça n'est pas notre
politique de l'immigration et par
conséquent il y a vraiment de grandes
évolutions
à ce moment là c'est impossible en
revanche si nous respectons le jeu des
institutions parlementaires et qu'il y a
un accord majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat sur un programme
d'action c'est tout autre chose mais ça
n'est pas un premier ministre LR puisque
le jour où il se met sous l'autorité du
Président de la République il n'est plus
à l'air et donc la question n'est pas de
savoir d'où vient le Premier ministre
mais s'il est indépendant du président
de la République et s'appuie sur une
majorité parlementaire pour mettre en
œuvre un programme de réformes qui
serait susceptibles de recevoir notre
approbation politique à l'évidence ça
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ça n'est
pas non plus la volonté du Président de
la République qui veut garder sa main
mise sur le gouvernement je vous
rappelle que le gouvernement dans la
Constitution
conduit la politique de la nation la
détermine il doit donc être indépendant
du président de la République ça a l'air
surprenant puisqu'on a pris l'habitude
du contraire mais c'est ça le président
et l'arbitre il doit assurer
la stabilité du gouvernement mais il ne
doit pas le commander comme il veut à
tout prix le faire même si c'est au prix
du fait que ce gouvernement est
minoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup Philippe merci d'avoir
été notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires faut-il réformer le
droit d'asile ce sera le débat entre la
sénatrice les républicains Valérie Boyer
et le porte-parole de renaissance Loïc
signore mais d'abord on va accueillir
notre prochaine invité Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol nous rejoint